so we do a lot of stuff obviously on
religious extremism around here and
there is no shortage of it but i found
this story that i thought was kind of
interesting showing possibly some of the
the benefits of religion it turns out
that seventh-day Adventists live an
average of ten years longer than the
average American life expectancy now
some of the places where people live the
longest include Sardinia Italy Okinawa
Japan has a lot to do with diet over
there but also other things spirituality
and other lifestyle activities but let's
look at why the Adventists live longer
they eat a plant-based diet which I'm
told that's good for you this doesn't
mean that they don't eat meat they just
don't need a lot of meat they also take
the idea of the Sabbath very seriously
so they are decompressing the stress
about eighty four percent of healthcare
dollars are spent because a bad food
choices inactivity and unmanaged stress
and they have cultural ways of managing
stress managing stress through their
Sabbath and then their social network
reinforces the right behavior so this is
interesting because this is kind of the
the good part of religion that everybody
sort of tosses away and because there's
so much crazy extremism usually I think
that's warranted um cara I'm gonna let
you start here as the as the resident
resident a resident atheist but when you
see something like this can you
acknowledge that there are some benefits
to Oh completely I mean this is not a
new concept either in the literature
that religion a kind of improves health
and religion improves measures of psych
like psychiatry and self-esteem and all
of these things like people seem to be
happier healthier now I don't think it
has anything to do with religion per se
I think it has everything to do with the
social structure that religion provides
for people unfortunately atheist you
know I think fundamental to being an
atheist is that we're not organized and
so what you don't have are the support
group you should start atheist
organization there are some people don't
go every Sunday and they don't know no
answer but that's there's so much
sitting and standing and everything
that's like yeah but you know it's like
a good workout for your ass seventh-day
Adventists are an interesting Bunch
they're kind of people call them the Old
Testament Christians so they're a bit
like like Jewish Christians in in some
of their customs and I think that a lot
of those have to do with really trying
so like Jews from Connecticut yeah
exactly like or like Jews from Texas I'm
so I grew up in Texas you know yeah
other southern girl I knew I liked you
um and I grew up mormon yeah and I'd be
interested to see if Mormons have
similar life expectancy because in in
the same vein Mormons don't drink they
don't drink caffeine they are really
involved in the social kind of stuff and
they're they're just healthy family
oriented people and of course that's
like the one thing I took away from it
when I grew up in a Mormon household I
also think there was something to be
said about like I've thought a lot about
you know when when you believe that
there's this God and you know he or she
or whatever is in control of our life
therefore you know we don't have to ask
the wise we don't the ponder the
questions we don't distress about well
what if I did this is this gonna happen
in my life in my career and my this and
my that and we are in constant we live
in anxiety and fear over all of these
questions but if you just kind of are in
a constant state of surrender a stress
doesn't exist like I was even holding my
newborn he was fighting taking a nap so
bad this thing that was so good for him
and I'm like why do you fight this thing
fight me all the time in the high chair
it's good for you to sit in the high
chair you know all these things they're
all good for you and you're fighting it
and I'm like we do the same as adults we
fight constantly the flow life is
happening and we're fighting against it
it's got to a just and caused so much
stress in our lives these people are not
fighting the flow yeah they're just
living their lives and doesn't
you know peaceful I I don't really have
any you know concerns about life I know
I'm being taken care of so of course
that's gonna help you live longer there
I like that what so how do we take that
piece the three of us all agree is a
good piece how do we take that flow
piece that that peaceful piece and then
not necessarily directly connect it to
religion but to connect it to just sort
of more evolved life a lot of people do
that with mindfulness like my meditation
and and some of the kind of concepts
that they take out of more Eastern
philosophies not necessarily religions
but i do want to point out that there
are also high levels of correlation
between intelligence and depression and
so yes there is something about
constantly questioning and being
scientific and thinking very hard that
might cause some psychiatric imbalances
and people or vice versa I mean there's
it's not causal here that I correlation
you're saying ignorance is bliss I'm
saying ignorance is listen I'd rather
not be ignorant I'd honestly rather die
ten years older that me I thought I
would and so I think it's it's really
about what is the goal here I don't want
to live that long in in the dark it's
just not that interesting to me well you
got you got to my last question is would
you would you sacrifice a couple years
on your life to feel that your life was
more enlightened rather than easy no I I
think that there you had a good point i
think there's a way to find that
sanctity within your own skull rather
than having to like be a part of a
religious sect i think that you can and
that is the mindfulness practice and
being conscious and awakened and it's
just it's harder to do whenever i guess
at a certain level intelligence when
you're constantly questioning and asking
questions that I'd rather ask the
questions I've been that way since I was
a child I'd rather just die 10 years
earlier yeah I'm sorry I'll fun I'm with
you and actually yeah yeah that's rough
for the kid but yeah besides that's fine
uh yeah I I mean I'm with both of them
on this and that's why we're doing this
show because i want to show you that
there can be some level of intelligence
and also some level
fun and that not everything is just this
terrible awful things right do something
yeah bring it on a causal I have to yeah
you can have both it's possible to have
both I mean just because you're smart
doesn't mean you're gonna die yeah yeah
that's not what you take away from them
I was at your house a couple weeks ago
you were a hell of a time in the middle
of the day in the pool and you're a
person so you can have fun that's smart
that's track same time